all right so then what's what's the
latest you were you were back in jail
again yeah what happened
I ended up
on meth again and I was on my come down
and I just I got it I don't want to go
into specifics but I got another charge
and it's not looking too good but I'm
trying my best to get everything I need
right now I already have like things set
up to get my ID back and everything so
you have another hearing coming up yeah
for this case and it is also the
previous one yeah
when is your next hearing on the night
so next week yeah make sure you don't
miss it yeah yeah you don't do that yeah
so you've been in jail before right like
in Florida um yeah what was that was for
again some kind of violence uh it was
just all a bunch of misunderstandings
but I'm really not violent I mean I
wasn't violent there I'm not I'm not
really a violent person I think it's
just like the drugs and everything I
mean I didn't do drugs in Florida ever
hey you didn't okay yeah but but this
last case was you stabbed somebody yeah
I'm sure there were details on that that
led to that right um yeah yeah there
were
how long were you in jail this time
I was in there for about a week I think
then Ben and I bailed you out again yeah
yeah thank you guys thank you guys for
that I haven't actually been getting
into any trouble
I haven't been getting in trouble
yeah every time I've seen you you seem
stable and headed yeah but I'm sure
drugs and alcohol might I change that
sometimes yeah yeah is that typically
how your problems come about is the
drugs in there yeah yeah yes it's the
comedown from the meth mixed with
alcohol combining also the mental
illnesses that people have it's like
it's not good yeah I mean I wouldn't
advise anybody to do that you know so so
you recognize you have some mental
issues and then there's also the drug
use yeah that whole combination is just
yeah cocktail for trouble yep you talk
to your mom at all she know what's going
on yeah we're actually kind of getting
along now
yeah
that's good
so you're kind of your future hinges on
how this court hearing goes in the next
two weeks you have one this week coming
up and when's the next one I'm not sure
I guess I'll just have to go to the
courthouse at some point this week
before the fourth and actually I should
probably do that either today or
tomorrow go to the courthouse it's just
to look up my cases and everything yeah
you don't want to screw that up no I
know I'm I actually do need another
cosigner for the bail bonds because Ben
didn't he didn't coast line
he took his cosign off so you're living
what is your attraction to Hollywood
Boulevard they're living on the street
there really is no attraction anymore I
just don't know where else to go I've
been trying to explore the rest of
Hollywood and everything and I've been
doing pretty good I mean it's not safe
on the boulevard that safe on the
boulevard anymore at night especially
yes I'll be slashed up your tent yeah
yeah somebody did but um I just got you
that ten I know no within the first
seven ten it lasted at night yeah it did
yeah but I fixed it so I'm gonna go to
the store and get like fishing wire and
a fishing hook because it holds better
than like thread okay
there's always little tricks of living
on the street aren't there huh there's
all these little tricks of living on the
street well so where do you think like
if if you end up not going to jail
prison whatever what do you what do you
plan on doing from here
I plan on getting an apartment
maybe just like saving up for a vehicle
and I actually might move out of LA at
some point because you know the crime
rate has gone up and everything and I
actually might have a job we're at a wig
shop yeah good for you
yeah if I can get that job though I'll
probably just like save up and
everything that's great
start renting like hotel rooms or I'm
actually safe and everything yeah I hope
that works out out the court court case
works out yeah court cases and I think
yes thing staying away from the drugs
and alcohol might be the first on my
list of things you should do
yeah I have actually been staying away
from alcohol and drugs every time I've
seen you you seem sober as a judge
yeah that's great all right well good
luck next week all right thank you
Thanks
all right then man so you just had your
hearing this morning and it went well
yeah you're smiling
yeah yeah it went very well so this was
the hearing for the stabbing right oh
yeah and so what does this mean for you
now you'll be free for a while or free
forever listen I think it means I stay
out of jail and they are going to try to
drop it down to a misdemeanor because I
told the truth about everything and he
was also very he wasn't man
so the person it used to have yes so he
was mad at the time but I don't think
he's mad now he was in court as well oh
no no she's gonna be in court tomorrow
though so you have another hearing
tomorrow yes but I know what's gonna
happen um is it okay if I say something
to him Richard if he's what okay I know
we're not supposed to talk whatever but
if you're watching this I am sorry it
was wrong with me
and wasn't in my right state of mind yes
I think that that's half your battle
more than half your battle is your
mental state right whether it's drugs or
alcohol or not taking your meds or
whatever yeah it seems like it's always
some combination of those things yeah
and so where did you life go from here
so you're not gonna be in jail or prison
it looks like I know so where do you go
now I go to I mean I guess I just stay
out on the on the outs on the street
yeah I'm gonna be saying it Ben's
tonight and then tomorrow I'm gonna go
back to Hollywood ensure to get my ID
set straight and everything I think I'm
gonna need a little help getting my ID
but a my social security income card in
food stamps and then tell me about the
last couple weeks of drug use psych meds
and alcohol oh that oh I haven't been on
any alcohol I haven't been drinking
well I drink one time but I haven't been
on drugs all I've been doing is smoking
weed and eating trying to figure out my
ID I had an appointment and they didn't
show up so it sounds like that from
America right there it's a most people
your age you're doing it can't be that
easy you know just to go to library and
have somebody hooking up with an ID yeah
I'm not sure exactly what your ideas are
but that sounds small just to get a new
one yeah but yeah nothing compared to
the court issues um yeah so and then
we're and what do you think would be the
most helpful step for you next get a job
go to rehab do tell me what go see your
mom in Florida I'd like to see my mom
but it's not to that point yet I told
her that I would be seeing her after I
get a place here that way she can come
and visit I can go there and visit I
don't want to get too comfortable there
honestly I mean I appreciate everybody
that's willing to help but I'm gonna try
do this on my own I think I can good for
you I might have a job all right
all I got to do is apply oh no oh did
you mention that there oh you mentioned
that in the last talk that you might
have a job opportunity well for which
one I forget which one is not a
restaurant like that
porta-potty no it's just setting up and
cleaning him out in every vote really
yeah I'm dirty jobs clean jobs whatever
yeah it's a job I mean if anybody can
help me out with a job that'd be cool um
with with with as many views as your
videos get I wouldn't be surprised that
some nice offer shows up that's all I'm
really wanting help with no you know
just a job or schooling schooling would
help like cosmetology but I think a jobs
more important at this point yeah thanks
that's exciting I'm happy for you I'm
glad you didn't get thrown in jail yeah
[Music]
things are looking up a little bit
that's great yeah
so I hope what that continues and uh
they will do another update down the
road here yeah
all right well thank you thank you for
coming by and uh good luck thank you all
right
you
you